so you mentioned checking in for people
who don't know I got put onto you
because big you signed you guys yeah
um shout out uh shout out to Big you
great guy
um somebody who's been a big homie to me
for [ __ ] almost 10 years now
um and you know what's dope about big
you is like I've never had him really
ask me for anything bro you don't ask
somebody for [ __ ] does that make sense I
think people have this because this
misconception about big you like bro
that's what
that's you just hit that on the head
right now people got the
biggest misconception about him like
that's probably the only person that can
go like
a joke for a joke with me like if I sit
down with with big you joked we can
roast bro for an hour he won't stop like
big U is really that type of of human
but everyone got the wrong perception
thinking that he was like this guy had
me [ __ ] bricks I'm at
um berries yeah and uh it's like three
in the morning
and I'm wearing a Texas Rangers hat oh
wait how do you know where this story
going so listen somewhere in the Texas
Rangers hat it's me and Brian Sampson my
manager of the fat old Filipino man
and uh I get a text and
it's like
actually just read it because I still I
have to still have it because it wasn't
that long ago
this was not that long ago and you know
big Hughes got my Android number
nobody's got this number unless you know
me forever
[ __ ] was I was I was like what the [ __ ]
where is it at here I already know where
this is going okay here it is
[Music]
um
he hits me up okay it's 1 30 in the
morning yeah I'm at I'm eating right bro
West up I'm like what's up man you good
he's like nothing I've been trying to
reach you I said I'm here always what's
the word I haven't seen any missed calls
I'm here with Brian Sampson he said I've
been trying to reach cuss also tell cuz
y'all need to pull up on a face to face
I'm like what the [ __ ]
I was like uh everything good and he put
issues dot dot dot I said what happened
I could call you now he's like man we
family pull up tonight
and now I lie to him oh yeah for sure I
say where at I'm all the way in Valencia
so I tell him I'm in Valencia right no
no he said why you got that t-hat on
though
don't say that kid that's what I stood
up
I said where is this [ __ ] at and
he stood up he was dying oh he got you I
said God damn man you had me lying to
you bro he said you had a two yet what's
up with a hat I'm like bro I don't
[ __ ] know it's blue and I like it
um It's a Good Hat
[ __ ] damn it's a bad hat to wear right
no for sure yeah so great guy though but
how did you guys uh how did he find
y'all uh I know for a while
um his
his kid his son his oldest Lil you is
like my best friend and his nephew
ephesia is like my other best friend so
in other words you've have you spent
some wild nights at Molly old house
that's legendary huh bro when I was
coming out here doing weekends I would
sleep there bro I remember never mind I
remember that we had a crazy night take
an elevator and we had like a we had
like a fight outside the house with like
some crazy dude
bro there was like eight dreads on the
floor the next morning we woke up at
Molly Mall's house me and fizzy walked
out we like damn what the [ __ ] is that
on the floor it was like eight dreads
would you were you all ever like staying
there because I feel like everybody I
stayed there for like a week at a time
for sure maybe you're like [ __ ] like
that I never could be there for too long
because you just didn't know what was
gonna happen at that house ever like bro
like yeah that was like that [ __ ] but
that she should have been recorded bro
you feel me that's just it's crazy
because how his house was here based on
how his house used to be in Vegas it's
like the PO polar opposite no exactly
like his old house it was like Fort Knox
no for sure like you had to know
somebody to be in there yeah they
weren't I feel like when he moved to LA
I go like you said you'd go over there
and be like what kind of gangster I had
so many inscriptions little situations
bro I've had so many little bro I've had
times where I'm I'm in there recording
and I walk out the booth it's like 20
people in the room after I'm like but
who the [ __ ] is this everyone's driving
this car everybody extrude out got Hood
tests I'm like oh what type of [ __ ] is
this bro like and I'm always upstairs
like it's okay guys I'll be downstairs
in a little he's up there [ __ ] three
girls at once [ __ ] three insane bed
you ever see his bed bruh pause I mean
but I've been in this bedroom pause
pause no homo yes but his bed is like uh
it's like it's like six California Kings
like stitched together for sure yeah
shout out to Mom free Molly Mo free mob
man that's my brother man great guy
that's a crazy [ __ ] right yeah
anyway so you you uh met him uh you met
big you because you knew his son yeah
okay you know I mean like we basically
all
all grew up together and like Uncle was
always with nip you know what I'm saying
so like to me like the only person I saw
that I knew that was like successful at
rap ever was knit you know what I'm
saying and I knew that Unk was the one
that did everything for nip the one that
got his career started one that did
everything for him so in my mind from
the time I was like in high school I was
like damn I need to be on that type [ __ ]
you know what I mean so uh
to me has always been like P Diddy you
know what I'm saying like that's how we
see him in in our area you know what I'm
saying for sure we see UNC is like P
Diddy like he's the way out the hood not
always knew that you know what I mean
like UNC is UNC is the way out yeah